IT'S A BIT DARK THERE BUT THERE
IS AN OFFICIAL GREETING PARTY.
HERE COMES THE SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE.
THAT WAS
SEEN EARLIER.
SHE WILL IN A SECOND SET FOOT ON
TIAWANESE TERRITORY.
THE FIRST TIME A SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE VISITED TAIJUAN SINCE
1997.
THAT WAS NEWT GINGRICH AT THE
TIME.
WILL RIPLEY, HE IS IN TAIPEI FOR
US.
TELL US HOW TAIJUAN HAS BEEN
PREPARING FOR THIS.
>> Reporter: WELL, THEY
CERTAINLY HAVEN'T BEEN TELLING
US ANYTHING PUBLICLY ON THE
RECORD REPORTABLE THAT WE CAN
SITE.
WE HAVE PIECING TOGETHER
CHECKING INFORMATION IN VARIOUS
LOCAL MEDIA.
HERE IS HOW WE CAN KIND OF
ASSUME AND BELIEVE BASED ON OUR
REPORTING, WE HAVE THE FOREIGN
MINISTER GREETING PELOSI AND SHE
MAY DO A FEW MORE THINGS AT THE
AIRPORT.
SHE'LL BE HEADING TO HER HOTEL.
WE BELIEVE IT'S A HOTEL NEAR
TAIPEI 101 YOU MENTIONED HAS
BEEN LIT UP WITH A WELCOME
MESSAGE SAYING SPEAKER PELOSI,
THAT WOULD BE THE MOST PUBLIC
DEMONSTRATION THAT WE SEEN
WELCOMING THE SPEAKER OTHER THAN
THAT, IT'S BEEN RADIO SILENCE
FROM THE PRESIDENT'S OFFICE ON
DOWN.
NOT EVEN REPORTER QUESTIONS ARE
BEING ANSWERED BY THE MINISTRY
OF DEFENSE.
IT WAS CHINESE STATE MEDIA THAT
TALKED ABOUT THE CHINESE CLAIMS
THAT MAY HAVE BEEN FLYING
TOWARDS THE MEDIAN, DIVIDING
TIAWANESE STRAIGHT THAT CHINA
NEVER AGREED TO RECOGNIZE.
THIS IS -- THEY DON'T -- THEY
CAN FLY ANYWHERE THEY WANT.
THEY THINK TAIJUAN IS A PROVINCE
OF THEIR COUNTRY EVEN THOUGH THE
COMMUNIST RULERS NEVER
CONTROLLED IT BUT YET, YOU HAVE
NOW NANCY PELOSI, YOU KNOW, ONE
OF THE HIGHEST LEVEL OFFICIALS
TO VISIT AS YOU MENTIONED 20
YEARS, VERY LONG TIME SINCE NEWT
GINGRICH IN '97.
SECOND IN LINE TO THE
PRESIDENCY.
SHE'LL BE MEETING WITH TAIJUAN'S
PRESIDENT TOMORROW AND
PARLIAMENT AND WE ALSO ASSUME
SHE MIGHT BE DOING OTHER
MEETINGS WITH BUSINESS LEADERS
HERE, AS WELL.
YOU MENTIONED THE CHIP
MANUFACTURERS, THE SEMI
CONDUCTORS.
SHE MIGHT VISIT SOME HISTORICAL
SITES.
IF SHE WILL BE SPENDING A FULL
DAY HERE, THERE IS GOING TO BE A
LOT OF THINGS THAT COULD HAPPEN
THAT COULD MAKE CHINA PRETTY
UNHAPPY BUT THE BIG UNKNOWN HOW
WILL THEY SHOW PROPAGANDA VIDEOS
AND RHETORICAL QUESTION IS FINE,
THAT COULD BE A RHETORICAL
QUESTION INTO A CONFIRMATION
MILITARY.
>> WE SEE, JOSEPH WU, WE SHOULD
NOTE THIS WASN'T OFFICIAL.
THEY'RE TREATING IT MORE LIKE A
NORMAL VISIT.
THERE ARE BEEN SEVERAL COM
COMPRISING DEMOCRAT LAWMAKERS
IN RECENT MONTHS.
THE DIFFERENCE HERE IS THAT THIS
IS THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
THIRD MOST POWERFUL ARGUABLY
DISCOVERING THAT.
THAT IS A FACT THAT CHINESE
LEADS TAKE SERIOUSLY SECOND IN
THE LINE TO THE PRESIDENCY.
WE HAVE SALINA IN BEIJING.
NOW THAT THIS HAS HAPPENED, HAVE
YOU SEEN REACTION OR HEARD
REACTION FROM CHINESE OFFICIALS
OR STATE MEDIA?
>> Reporter: WE HAVE JUST HEARD
FROM STATE MEDIA THERE ARE PLA
FIGHTER JETS CROSSING THE
TAIJUAN STRAIGHTS.
WE HAVE NOT CONFIRMED HOW FAR
THEY'RE GOING TO TAKE THAT.
CHINA HAS BEEN REGULARLY SENDING
WAR PLANES AROUND TAIJUAN'S
SELF-DECLARED AIR DEFENSE ZONE
SO FE WITH NOT CONFIRMED WHERE
THAT WILL GO.
MOST EXPERTS I'VE BEEN SPEAKING
TO SAY WE COULD SEE A MIXTURE OF
ECONOMIC COERCION AND DIPLOMATIC
COERCION INCLUDING A SHOW OF THE
MILITARY FORCE AND THE BUILDUP
TO THE MOMENT COINCIDING WITH
CELEBRATIONS FOR CHINA'S
MILITARY DAY.
WE HAVE SEEN MORE OF THESE
DRILLS HAPPENING AROUND CHINA
SEAS INCLUDING IN THE PROVINCE
THAT IS CLOSEST TO TAIJUAN AND
SEEN THE ESCALATION PREPARING
FOR WAR AND MILITARY PROPAGANDA
VIDEOS BUT MOST DO NOT BELIEVE
CHINA WOULD ENGAGE IN DIRECT
HOSTILE REACTION BUT THE CONCERN
WITH THE MILITARY HARDWARE ON
THE GROUND, HOW DOES THAT
INCREASE THE RISK OF A
MISCALCULATIONS HERE?
THE OTHER KEY QUESTIONS ARE
RAMIFICATIONS OF THIS WILL LAST
FAR BEYOND HER ACTUAL VISIT.
HOW COULD THIS INCREASE THE
COERCION OF TAIJUAN MOVING
FORWARD IN THE COMING YEARS?
I WANT TO GET TO MANU RAJU FROM
CAPITOL HILL.
HE'S GOT A NEW STATEMENT FROM
THE SPEAKER.
WHAT ARE YOU PICKING UP?
>> Reporter: THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME SHE CONFIRMED OR TALKED
PUBLICLY ABOUT THIS TRIPE TO
TAIJUAN.
THIS HAS BEEN UNDER WRAPS AND
SHE'S REFUSED TO DISCUSS THIS
BECAUSE OF SECURITY CONCERNS AND
IN THE AFTERMATH OF HER ARRIVAL.
SHE'S EXPLAINING WHY SHE IS IN
FACT GOING TO TAIJUAN TO FIND
THE CHINESE COMMUNIST
LEADERSHIPS DEMANDS.
SHE SAYS THE CONGRESSIONAL
DELEGATION VISIT IS PART OF THE
UNWAVERING COMMITMENT TO SUPPORT
TAIJUAN'S VIBRANT DEMOCRACY AND
SAYS THIS IS PART OF A BROADER
TRIP TO THE REGION.
THEY'RE GOIN G ING TO SINGAPORE
MALAYSIA, SOUTH KOREA AND JAPAN.
SHE SAYS THAT AMERICA'S
SOLIDARITY WITH THE 23 MILLION
PEOPLE OF TAIJUAN IS MORE
IMPORTANT NOW TODAY THAN EVER AS
THE WORLD FACES THE CHOICE
BETWEEN AUTOCRACY AND DEMOCRACY
AND THEN SHE GOES ON TO TALK
ABOUT HOW THEIR VISIT IS -- SHE
DEFENDS THE VISIT.
SHE SAYS AMERICA -- SHE SAYS
THERE IS NO WAY IN VIOLATION
WITH AMERICA'S POLICIES TOWARDS
TAIJUAN, WHICH IS A WAY TO PUSH
BACK AGAINST THE CRITICISM FROM
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT ABOUT
THIS TRIP SAYING THAT THE VISIT
IS ONE OF SEVERAL DELEGATIONS
AND IN NO WAY CONTRADICTS
LONG-STANDING UNITED STATES
POLICY GUIDED BY THE TAIJUAN
RELATIONS ACT OF 1979 AND THE
I
SIXTH ASSURANCES AND THE UNITED
STATES OPPOSES UNILATERAL
EFFORTS TO CHANGE THE STATUS
QUO.
DEFENDING THIS TRIP AND
EXPLAINING IT'S NOT IN HER VIEW
OF A BREACH OF U.S. POLICY IN
THE HANDLING OF TAIJUAN BUT
EXPLAINING WHY SHE'S THERE TO
PROMOTE DEMOCRATIC VALUES AND
SAY THE UNITED STATES STANDS
WITH THE PEOPLE OF TAIJUAN.
KATE?
>> STICK WITH ME.
LET'S GO TO KYLIE ATWOOD.
HER LANDING WILL BE A WELCOME
ADDITION TO THE CONVERSATION
FROM THE STATE DEPARTMENT.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
WHAT SHE'S SAYING IN PART IN
THIS STATEMENT MIRRORS WHAT WE
HAVE HEARD FROM THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION OVER THE LAST 24,
48 HOURS WITH OFFICIALS
INCLUDING THE SECRETARY OF STATE
MAKING THE ARGUMENT LOOK, NANCY
PELOSI'S TRIP TO TAIJUAN IS NOT
UNPRECEDENTED SAYING OTHER
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS VISITED
TAIJUAN, A SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
VISITED 25 YEARS AGO, KATE.
THE CIRCUMSTANCES TODAY ARE
INCREDIBLY DIFFERENT BUT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN
CALLING ON CHINA, NOT TO
ESCALATE THINGS BUT THE
SECRETARY OF STATE SAYING IF
THERE IS A CRISIS THAT'S CREATED
HERE THAT WOULD BE ENTIRELY ON
CHINA.
I ALSO THINK, KATE, IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REALIZE THAT THIS
VISIT BY THE SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE ISN'T HAPPENING IN A
VACUUM AND COMES AS U.S.
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS HAVE BEEN
SAYING PUBLICLY THAT CHINA IS
WORKING HARD TO MILITARY
TAKEOVER TAIJUAN.
WHILE THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
SAYS THIS ONE POLICY STANDS AND
SPEAKER PELOSI SAID IN HER
STATEMENT, THIS PHYSICAL SHOW OF
SUPPORT IN THE CONTEXT OF CHINA
TO TAKE OVER TAIJUAN IS IN AND
OF ITSELF COMPLICATED.
>> LET ME GET TO SUSAN GLASSER,
CNN STAFF WRITER FOR THE NEW
YORKER.
SUSAN, A LOT OF STATEMENTS WILL
BE ISSUED AND A LOT WILL BE
SAID.
WHAT DO YOU SEE THE REAL IMPACT
BEING OF THIS VISIT FOR THE
U.S., FOR U.S. CHINA RELATIONS?
>> LOOK, IT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
ONE THING IS CAN YOU RECALL THE
SIMILAR AMOUNT OF BREATHLESS
ATTENTION BEING GIVEN TO A
CONGRESSIONAL DELEGATION TRIP,
EVEN ONE BY NANCY PELOSI IN
RECENT YEARS?
PART OF CHINA'S THREADS HAVE
BACKFIRED IN THE SENSE THEY HAVE
CALLED ENORMOUS ATTENTION TO
PELOSI'S TRIP, ALMOST CERTAINLY
PART OF HER INTENTION TO SEND A
MESSAGE TO CHINA AND HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES AS WELL IT'S BOTH
PARTIES IN THE UNITED STATES AND
NOT JUST THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
THAT IS DEDICATED TO STOPPING
CHINA'S EFFORTS TO TAKE OVER
TAIJUAN AND DENY THE PEOPLE OF
TAIJUAN THEIR LEGITIMATE RIGHT
TO DETERMINE THEIR OWN
GOVERNMENT AND FUTURE.
SHE'S HAD ENORMOUS VISIBILITY
FOR HER TRIP, HEIGHTENED BY THE
BLUL
BLUSTER AND THREATS FROM CHINA.
THAT'S ONE THING.
THE OTHER THING IS I FEAR THIS
MAY REPRESENT A NEW PHASE ON THE
ESCALATION WHICH FEELS LIKE AN
INEVITABLE CRISIS OVER THE
STATUS OF TAIJUAN GIVEN --
>> I WAS GOING TO ASK YOU ABOUT
THAT.
YOU'VE SAID THAT ONE CHINA
EXPERT TOLD YOU RECENTLY THAT
THIS VISIT MIGHT BE HIS VERSION
OF WAG THE DOG TAIL.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
>> FIRST OF ALL, THERE IS COME
MES
-- DOMESTIC POLITICS AS CHINA
IS AND PING IS LOOKING TOWARD AN
IMPORTANT PARTY CONGRESS IN THE
FALL IN NOVEMBER, THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT MESSAGE FOR HIM.
HE WANTS TO SENT A MESSAGE HE'S
THE TOUGH GUY ON TAIJUAN AND
PROVOKING A CRISIS OVER THIS
VISIT ESCALATING THIS INTO MORE
OF A CONFRONTATION, USING IT AS
A COVER POTENTIALLY TO TAKE MORE
CONCRETE ACTIONS.
THAT'S WORRISOME.
I THINK THERE ARE POLITICS ON
BOTH SIDES OF THIS BUT THE REAL
WORRY IS THAT WE'RE JUST
HURDLING DOWN THE ROAD BECAUSE
THE RHETORIC FROM VLADIMIR
PUTIN, DENYING UKRAINE'S RIGHT TO EXIST
ALSO THE VIEW THAT XI JINPING TAKES TOWARD TAIWAN